that's actually the real misogyny is you
trying to destroy each other's lives and
ruin each other's relationships for
jealousy we're not the massages because
I'm speaking aggressive it's misogynist
to not want a woman to be a mother which
is the happiest State a woman could ever
be in how can you say that what did I
say that's wrong what is wrong about
what I said just say what you just said
I'm not repeating it for you like see
you right now perfect example you didn't
even hear what I said it's the way I
said it and now you're upset you don't
even know why you're mad I know what you
said but what I said hear yourself
speaking okay what did he say that was
wrong it's how I said it
what did he say that was wrong what
about all the barren women what about
women that can't have kids
yeah but those are outliers wait have
you ever have you ever spoken to a woman
that can't have kids that's Baron yes
they're usually miserable they're not
happy with that and if you talk to you
know what percentage of women that don't
have kids are happy with it less than 20
percent
the majority of women that don't have
kids are not happy